مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز دويري اهلا بك لواء دويري
سنبدا بالتحدي التحليل لكن قبل ذلك سيكون
معنا على الخريطه التفاعليه زميل محمود
الكن للوقوف عند ابرز التطورات الميدانيه
في مختلف مناطق القطاع والبدايه من الشمال
بالتاكيد وسيله هناك معارك تدور في كامل
القطاع مع القصف لكن التركيز ثقل العمليات
هو في شمال قطاع غزه تحديدا جنوب مدينه
غزه اضافه الى غرب خان يونس دعونا نشاهد
هذه الخريطه هنا اللون الازرق هو دوما
لمنطقه العسكريه المغلقه في غلاف غزه
اللون الاصفر هو لمناطق مناورات اسرائيليه
وليس ارتكاز او توغل وانما هي حركه
الاليات الاسرائيليه اذا ما شاهدنا هنا في
الشمال تغيرت خلال الايا الايام الماضيه
هذه النقاط هنا لتراجع الاليات في شمال
مدينه غزه ولكن في الجنوب العمليات
العسكريه تبدو حركه الاليات فيها هي من
اتجاه الجنوب ومن ثم توغل شمالا من تل
الهواء والشيخ عجين ومحاوله للضغط باتجاه
المركز كيف يحدث هذا في شمال قطاع
غزه هنا سنشاهد الخريطه مره اخرى بشكل
اقرب اليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تحاول
التوغل من هذه النقطه ارتكاز في تل الهواء
ومن ثم التقدم بهذا الاتجاه لكن عمليات
المقاومه ايضا مركز ثقل العمليات كان
هنا و وهنا في هذه المناطق ايضا كان هناك
حسب ما قالت كتائب قسام انه تم استهداف
وقنص نائب قائد اللواء في هذه المناطق اذا
ثقه العمليات استهداف للاليات استهداف
لناقلات الجند استهداف حتى ل حوامه طائره
هيليكوبتر كان في هذه المناطق ومن الملاحظ
ان العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي بدات تتخذ اشكالا مختلفه
في المناورات تعتمد على عدد اليات اقل
محاوله للتوغل واستهداف اهداف محدده
وبالتالي ربما تحاول قوات جيش الاحتلال
العثور على هدف ما لكن من الواضح من
الاخبار ان مركز الثقل ثقل العمليات هو في
جنوب غرب مدينه غزه اضافه الى الجهه
الغربيه هذا يتواتر كذلك مع الجنوب قطاع
غزه اذا ما توجهنا اليه تحديدا نتحدث عن
هنا في خان يونس اذا في خان يونس مركز ثقل
العمليات هو في هذه النقاط
هنا بالقرب من الصناعه والمخيم محاولات
التوغل دوما
باتجاه المستشفيات ولكن صور الاقمار
الصناعيه خلال الايام الماضيه او خلال حتى
حتى يوم امس اظهرت لنا ان التكتيكات كانت
مختلفه بعض الشيء بالنسبه لهذا اللون
الاصفر حيث كانت ترتكز الاليات في هذه
النقطه هنا حوالي 25 اليه اذا ما اقتربنا
اليها اكثر منها سنلاحظ بانها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان تسوي المربعات
السكنيه بالكامل وتحاول الضغط بهذا
الاتجاه طبعا كيف تعمل هذه العمليات لماذا
جنوب مدينه غزه وجنوب غرب مدينه غزه
وعمليه القنص الاخيره كل هذا سيكون معك
وسيله واللواء فايز الدويري في التحليل
العسكري بالفعل شكرا جزيلا لك محمود لواء
دويري ونبدا بهذا الخبر العاجل الذي اعلن
عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي وهو مقتل نائب قائد
لواء في سلاح الهندسه وياتي طبعا هذا
الخبر بعد ما اكدت كتائب القسام اغتيالها
او مقتل هذا الضابط ما تعليقك يعني اولا
هو مقتل نائب قائد كتيبه هندسه وليس لواء
لا يوجد في الجيش الاسرائيلي الويه هندسه
يوجد كتائب وهي تعود الى اللواء 401 لانه
كل تشكيل عسكري يكون هناك اسلحه اسناد
منها اسلحه اسناد عمليات كال المدفعيه
والهندسه وعمليات اسناد لوجستي اداري
التموين و وشبه ذلك فالخبر الذي جاء جاء
عن رائد برتبه رائد ضابط برتبه رائد قا
نائب قائد كتيبه الهندسه وهذه الكتيبه
نلاحظ بانه الجيش الاسرائيلي هو الوحيد في
العالم الذي يوظف استخدام الجارفه من اجل
القتال في المناطق المبنيه ولاحظنا هذا في
معظم العمليات الان الذي جرى في هذه
المنطقه هناك عمليات قنص واستهداف متبادل
من الطرفين سواء كان من قبل فسائر
المقاومه او من قبل جيش الاحتلال لكن ما
يجري في جنوب غرب وجنوب اي والوسط الغربي
لانه الان العمليات تم توسيع اطارها
بالامس كنا اول امس كنا نتحدث عن الشيخ
تحدثنا عن تل الهوا تحدثنا عن مربع
الجامعات تحدثنا عن مربع الجوازات الان
نتحدث عن مخيم الشاطئ يعني الان هذه
المنطقه يبدو ان لدى جيش الاحتلال معلومات
عن بعض الامور سواء تتعلق بالانفاق تتعلق
بقاده عسكريين تتعلق بالرهاب غير معروف ما
هو وبالتالي هو يركز على العمل في ضمن هذه
المنطقه تقريبا تاخذ عمق يزيد عن 2 م حسب
اتجاه حركه القوات انما هي النقطه الساخنه
في شمال القطاع ما عداها لا يوجد عمليات
تذكر باستثناء عمليات القصف وهذا ما قاله
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي قال
نواجه حرب ضاريه في مخيم الشاطئ على وجه
التحديد لكن لنعود الى عمليه القنص هذه
التي استهدفت هذا نائب القائد هذا ما الذي
نعرفه عن سلاح الهندسه وما الدور الذي
يقوم به في هذه المعركه هناك العديد من
الادوار التي يقوم بها سلاح الهندسه سواء
كان للجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي او لاي جيش
في العالم هناك يعني واجبات محدده في
الادبيات العسكريه في كل دول العالم لكنها
تختلف من حيث الاهميه والاولويه ومن حيث
الظروف القائمه
الان غزه مدينه
الانفاق وبالتالي هناك
كتيبه متخصصه بالانفاق و خضعت لتدريب
مستمر لفتره طويله على انفاق مشابهه في
منطقه بئر السبع
وبالتالي هذه الكتيبه متخصصه في الانفاق
هناك جهد هندسي اخر يكون مخصص لمرافقه
الوحدات المقاتله من اجل شق الطرق ومن اجل
ازاله الركام الى غير ذ ولاحظي في صور
الاقمار
الصناعيه استخدام او بناء السواتر
الترابيه لانه هو قتال في مناطق مبنيه
عندما تكون الدبابه مكشوفه واضحه وبالتالي
يتم استهدافها بسهوله فكلما توقفت هذه
الوحدات ولو لفتره قصيره من الزمن لمده
ساعات يتم عمل وتنفيذ سواتر ترابيه في بعض
الحالات من متر ونص الى مترين ارتفاع
الساتر الترابي اذا طبيعه المعركه هي التي
تفرض الدور واولويات هذا الدور بالنسبه
لشريحه الهندسه ا وهو الذي فقد الان نائب
قائد كتيبه مثل ما قلنا ومثل ما اعلن عنه
الجيش الاسرائيلي ما الذي يعنيه في هذه
المعارك وفي الشمال ان يقتل الضباط في
الجيش الاسرائيلي الضباط يتواجدوا في
الخطوط الاماميه للقتال وتحدثنا عن ذلك
كثيرا
يعني اعداد الضباط الذين قتلوا في هذه
الحمله البريه اكبر من المعتاد عليه في
الحروب الاخرى ه هذا له جمله جمله من
الاسباب احد هذه الاسباب ان الوحدات
المدرعه في كثير من الحالات مسؤول الدبابه
يكون ضابط وبالتالي بدل ان يكون في الفصيل
ضابط واحد يكون ثلاث ضباط هذا في بعض
الحالات وليس في كل الحالات
اثنين الان عندما نتحدث عن احتياط وجيش
نظامي الجيش النظامي اكثر مهاره وقدره على
الدخول في المعركه ف في الجيش في الويه
الاحتياط الاحتياط التي تتلقى تدريب سنوي
محدود اهليتها وتاهيل في القتال لم يكن لن
يكون كبيرا وبالتالي يتم الزج بالضباط الى
الخطوط الاماميه حتى يكونوا قادرين على
اتخاذ الاجراء الصحيح واعطاء الامر الصحيح
وبناء تقدير الموقف الصحيح وهذا الجميع
يذكر الكمين ثلاثي ثلاثي الابعاد كما كما
وصف في ذلك اليوم قائد فصيل قائد س قائد
كتيبه اشتركوا جميعهم في محاوله تخليص
مجموعه وبالتالي هذا يعني ان هناك درجه
التاهيل لضباط الصف متدنيه جدا فيتم الزج
بالضباط حتى يكونوا اقدر على اتخاذ القرار
والزج بهم في الصفوف الاماميه مثل ما قلت
هم وربما ما يفسر هذه الاعداد الكبيره في
الاصابات نتحدث الان عن
350 ضابط وجندي كذلك من بين المصابين وهذه
طبعا ارقام الجيش الرسمي اسرائيلي وهي
ربما قد تكون اكبر بذلك من كثير يعني لو
احصنا للفيديوهات اللي تم عرضها فقط ناخذ
الدبابات وعربات النمر وناخذ التدمير
الكلي وليس التعطيل وافترضنا ان هذه عربه
النمر يوجد فيها 11 شخص والدبابه يوجد
فيها اما اربعه او عشره لانه في بعض
الحالات تحمل سته جنود فاذا اخذنا ارقا
اعداد الدبابات التي عرضت في فيديوهات
قسام وبقيه الفصائل سنجد ان هذا الرقم
اضعاف اضعاف ما تم الاعلان عنه دون الحديث
عن عمليات القنص او اي عمليات فقط
الدبابات التي دمرت هي وناقلات النمر
تدميرا كليا الاعداد المتواجده فيها اضعاف
اضعاف ما ما ما يعن عنه جيش الاحتلال ا
الان فقط اللواء دويل اسمح لي نعرض هذا
الفيديو لكتائب
القسام وهي مشاهد من دك كتائب القسام
الاشتراك مع سرايا القدس تحش دت في العدو
في محاور مدينه غزه بقذائف الهون مثل ما
جاء هنا لنتابع وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن
الله رمى سنقوم الان باذن الله بدك الحشود
الاسرائيليه الاشتراق مع الاخوه اذا نشاهد
هنا لواء الدويري ل هو قذا الان هو يعمل
الم يقال يعمل المعايره على نظام الملذات
من اجل التوجيه وتحديد نقطه سقوط هذه القض
طبعا تحدثنا كثيرا هذه هي اسلحه تستخدم
لرمايه منطقه وليس لرمايه نقطه ولكنها
فاعله ومؤثره خاصه الهاون 120 ملم ما مدى
فاعليتها وفيما هي فاعله جدا ضد الاليات
المدولبه خفيفه التصفيح وضد الافراد
الموجودين في العلاء ض العراء او ضد
المستودعات لكن قد تكون الفاعليه اذا ما
كانوا متحصنين داخل الدبابه او داخل عربه
النمر يكون التاثير اقل
ا لكن الملفت انه هذا الان عمل مزدوج يعني
شرايا القدس مع القسام مما يعني تفعيل
غرفه العمليات المشتركه بان التخطيط مشترك
والتنفيذ مشترك والى ماذا يؤشر ذلك نشاهد
الكثير من العمليات التي باتت مشتركه بين
الرف ظروف ظروف المعركه ظروف المعركه طول
مده الحرب نتحدث 123 يوم وبالتالي يجب ان
يكون هناك تناغم كامل ويجب ان يكون هناك
اقتصاد في الجهد يعني الان يتم الاقتصاد
في الجهد على حساب المهاره والجوده لانه
كذلك هذا فسائل محاصره من سنوات وسنوات
وبالتالي طال امد الحرب عليه ان يوظف
الامكانات التوظيف الامثل وربما هذا
التوظيف الذي اعطاهم قوه وهذا ما دفع رئيس
هيئه
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي زار منطقه في شمال
غزه لم
تحدد قال نواجه حرب ضاريه هذا بعد
124 يوم مازال الجيش الاسرائيلي يت مخر
عندما عندما القسام كتب عندما تم الكشف عن
نفق قالوا لهم المهمه انجزت وصلت متاخرا
وانا اقول اعتراف متاخر الكل يتابع ونتابع
على مدار الساعه ونعلم ماذا يجري على ارض
المعركه هي من اقصى الحروب التي خاضها جيش
الاحتلال يعني علما انها ضد قطاع غزه 365
كيلو كيلومتر مربع ي هذه بالنسبه له كانت
من اقصى الحروب والاعداد الاصابات من اعلى
الاصابات وبالتالي كما يقال المخفي اعظم
لانه ستظهر تبدي الايام حجم الخسائر التي
مني بها جيش الا و على رغم من ذلك جالنت
بالامس كان يتحدث بتفاؤل ويقول نتوقع ان
انهيار كتيبه خان يونس اللي معركه تمتد
اسبوع كيف يمكن فهم هذا التناقض هذا ما
قاله قبل تقريبا ثلاث اسابيع او اربعه
اسابيع عن غزه اعاد نفس الكلام تمكنا من
تفكيك البنيه التنظيميه ل لحماس قتلنا
9000 من اصل 12000 افقدنا القدره على
اداره المعركه ولكن خرج رئيس الاركان
هاليفي وقال لا حماس استعادت قدرتها وبناء
قوتها مره اخرى فالكلام الذي تحدث به قبل
اسابيع عن غزه يتحدث به عن خان يونس لهذا
السبب الاسبوع فتره قصيره لمن يعطى العمر
وسنلاحظ هل كلامه دقيق ام غير دقيق ونتوجه
الان الى الجنوب الى خان يونس على وجه
التحديد لنعرض
هذا الفيديو لكتائب او لسرايا القدس
نتابع
ا هذا
الفيديو لاستخدام سرايا القدس صواريخ جراد
جراد ا يعني هو متوفر عندهم جراد واحد
وجراد اثنين المدى 20 كيلو و40 كيلو وهو
سلاح تقريبا انتج عام 1963 قديم جدا
واستخدم من قبل الجيش السوفيتي والان لكن
هنا يستخدم من منصه اطلاق فرديه بينما هو
المرصه اطلاق الحقيقيه في الحروب العاديه
يكون اربعه طبقات كل طبقه ع صواريخ اي
بمعنى الراجمه الواحده ترمي 40 صاروخ
بينما هنا يستخدم بقاعده اطلاق منفرده هذ
هذه الامكانيات الموجوده لكن يتم توظيفها
بصوره جيده وهذا ما نشاهده هنا في حي
الامل معركه حي الامل التي بالامس كنا
نتحدث عن انها ضاريه وتستخدم فيها اسلحه
ثقيله لاشتباكات كانت قويه نعلق اكثر على
هذه الصور الان هذه الصواريخ كما صواريخ
الجراد لم لم يتم بيان هل هي جراد واحد ام
جراد اثنين لانه تقريبا الاثنين يكون محسن
عن واحد اكثر فعاليه اكثر دقه الى غير ذلك
لكن هذا هو السلاح الموجود وكانت الحديث
فقط عن استخدام صواريخ جراد اتوقع ان تكون
جراد واحد ولكن تم توظيفها بصوره جيده
لانه في النهايه اصابت الاهداف التي
استهدفت ا نتابع الان لواء دويري فيديو
اخر لكن هذه المره هذا الفيديو
نشره الجيش الاسرائيلي للمعارك في خانيونس
نتابع هذ الجارفه عمليات التدمير الممنهج
تدمير كل شيء امامهم وهذ اطل استخدام
الرشاشات طبعا كالعاده نشاهد جانب واحد من
المعركه لا نشاهد الطرف في الاخر لواء
دويري هذه الوحده اسمها الوحده اجوز ما
الذي نعرفه عن ه هي من وحدات النخبه هذه
من وحدات النخبه تخضع لتدريب اي مهاري
عالي جدا
وبالتالي تكلف بالمهام الصعبه تعتبر هي
قوات النخبه وراس الحربه في العمليات
القتاليه يعني وهذه تعود الى الويه النخبه
جفعاتي جولاني و ما شابه ذلك هي تعتبر من
القوات النخبه المتميزه والقادر على ت فيذ
المهام الصعبه الجيش في هذه المعركه يقول
انه يحارب وجها لوجه لكن طبعا لا نشاهد
الطرف نشاهد الوجه الاول فقط ولا نشاهد
الوجه الثاني طبعا هذا اذا كان الفيلم
حقيقي ولم يتم
اي تصويره بعد انتهاء المعركه في هذه
المنطقه نعم يجب ان يكون من مسافه قريبه
لكن مشكله الافلام هذه لا تظهر الجانب
الاخر بالمطلق فيما افلام القسام و شرائع
القدس تبين طرفي
المعادله نشاهد هنا هذا الجندي وهو مدجج
بالسلاح ومحمي بشكل جيد ورغم ذلك الاصابات
والاستهداف تتكرر من قبل المقاومه لاسما
عندما يتعلق الامر بان يكون الجندي داخل
المباني السكنيه الارض تخدم صاحبها الارض
تخدم صاحبها ابن الارض يعرفها كما يقال
بالشبر وبالتالي المقاتلين من فصائل
المقاومه يعرفوا كل كل المداخل وكل الامور
وكل الزوايا وبالتالي لهذا ينجحوا في
عمليات القنص في استخدام التي بي جي في
استخدام الياسين لانه يخرج من هو هو ابن
هذا ابن هذا الارض ويعرف كيف يتصرف هذا
قادم المعلومات الاستخباريه له ليست
بالمطلق دقيقه لانه هناك فشل استخباري من
7 اكتوبر حتى هذا اليوم اذا هو يدخل الى
منطقه فقط بعد
ان يثخن بها قصفا وتدميرا ومن ثم يتحرك
ولكن يفاجا بان المقاتل خرج له من الانفاق
من نقطه وكما شاهدنا في بعض احد الافلام
كان مسافه 10 متر ما بين الدبابه وفتحه
النفق شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايز دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا
كالعاده هنا في الاستوديو نشكرك جزيل
الشكر خت